um hi my name is ilya nemenmann i'm at
emory university in the department of
physics and biology i'm a theoretical
biophysicist
and i was asked today to
give a talk about
our recent results on theoretical
modeling of neurodynamics
and
first of all i want to thank thank the
organizers of the meeting for inviting
me and thanks to all of the
supporting personnel for actually making
this happen
um this should this is supposed to be
about a 15-minute talk and we'll see how
it actually shapes up in real life
okay so with that what i'm going to talk
about is the null models of large neural
networks
this is a work which is primarily based
on two
[Music]
papers
and
so they talk will be structured in you
know in the following way first i will
talk a bit about
uh what i think are some of the
challenges about building a theory in
neuroscience theory of a brain and then
i will go very quickly through two um
case studies two examples where we have
been able to develop what i think are
better normal models and uh most
other
groups are using
this work has been done in collaboration
with uh two other researchers audrey
sederberg was a postdoc at emory and i
was a faculty at the university of
minnesota
and mia was an undergraduate student
here at emory and our graduate student
at nyu
so let's start with the
following thing
now about seven years ago
here at emory we organized a
computational science meeting and
in some of the sessions at that meeting
there was
expressed a common opinion by more than
one research more than one scientist
that the final theory of biological
systems will be large multi-scale
computational models and we need more
and more experimental data to specify
details of such models
so the final theory of the brain is
going to be basically a large electronic
brain
with the one-to-one accurately simulated
physical processes and there's a lot of
problems that i see with this statement
so the first one is that
uh
what is really the final theory of the
brain right do we even need a theory of
everything all of the processes all of
the things happening at the same time
in
any biological system such as brain or
in fact in any physical system right so
if i were to ask you know what is a
final theory of this uh coffee cup right
of this coffee mug um you probably would
not be able to answer this question it
would depend on which kind of questions
you actually are asking the theory to
answer do we
want to understand how quickly the
scatter is going to drop if i let it go
do i understand if it's going to crack
do i understand
um how the color of
change because if i put it on the
window sill and so on and so forth there
is no a single theory that explains
everything there is to explain about
this cup we ask specific questions and
we build theories for specific questions
right
and so in my opinion the um
of the paradigm that people have
developed in physical sciences that we
do not model bold orders with quarks
um
suggests to us that the theories is that
of inanimate systems or of this
very complex biological systems of brain
that we're interested in theories must
be based on small sets of degrees of
freedom and these degrees of freedom
must be relevant for a limited set of
the phenomena that we want to explain
right we need to know
the mass of the object in order to
figure out how it responds to a force
attached to it but we don't really need
to know all of the details where exactly
this mars is organized right in a
similar sense in the brain we'll
probably need to know some structures uh
of or the brain some dynamics of the
brain to give answers to some specific
questions but we will never need to know
everything and so the goal of theory in
some sense is to find what are these
relevant degrees of freedom that we need
to identify to experimentally measure
from which we can can build um answers
to specific sets of you know very well
focused questions that have been asked
so um
there are
in general many different ways how
theory has been
used in neuroscience right i'm going to
leave aside all of the old work from
hush can
hacksta and so on and so forth and just
focus maybe on the last five to ten
years
so what we have understood
is that
the neural circuits can actually be
modeled
mathematically in all of the details
there is probably no paradigm change at
this level of small circuits with enough
of
experiments measuring all the details of
this involved cells and their couplings
and so on and so forth and with enough
modeling which could be dynamical system
style modeling or stochastic processes
style modeling or yet many other
different approaches we can understand
the circle right and it could really be
that the there is no theory in
neuroscience right we are always forced
to forever be forced to build this
detailed model sort of like you know
people were saying in 2014 at the cns
meeting ever larger ever more detailed
models and populate them with data and
that's possible
uh personally
i'm not that happy about that right
because i'm not sure what i'm doing in
science and secondly i also believe it's
probably not quite right because for me
to be able to work with my brain right
for me to be able to understand what the
world is around using my brain there
have to be an ability to
summarize the
details in you know summarize the
activity and some number of interesting
variable degrees of freedoms i don't
have the entire age of the universe
personally to learn how my brain works
right i don't
have the age of the universe to learn
how to use my brain to control my
muscles
if
i'm able to trade in the world it's only
because there are this
underlying low dimensional degrees of
freedom that are learnable and that's
what we're going to focus on and so in
this regard
the one role of theory that people have
focused on is
based on various you know principles
optimization principles that we need to
control our muscles quickly we need to
not lose enough
not use a lot of energy for that we need
to be able
to um send information efficiently and
so on and so forth and from that we can
predict the circuit structure we can
understand why the brain is structured
the way it is structured and a lot of
other people i'm sure we'll talk about
that what i'm going to focus on is a
slightly different
question that theory i think can answer
in neuroscience so what
has become clear in the last decade or
so is that measuring thousands of
variables about the activity or the
structure of the brain is relatively
easier than knowing how to interpret
these measurements
we can record a population activity from
nowadays 10 000 neurons so we can record
connect connections uh between thousands
of neurons and
what do we do with that what does it
mean when should we be surprised we sort
of understand that more is different
that
interesting emergent features are going
to show up as you put thousands of
neurons together but our intuition fails
when we record from those large
populations of neurons or we measure
structures of um
activity patterns of thousands of
neurons right we do not know when we
need to be surprised if we
get a certain correlation if we see a
certain feature in the data it may be
surprising or it may be something that
is
something that one should expect right
and we don't know when the two
but the boundary between the two
and so
what's going to happen in this talk is
um even though
brains certainly are not random networks
what i will show here is that many
seemingly surprising results that people
have sought as surprising in the context
of
traditional
um details detailed specific neural
network models
these results are modeled exceedingly
well
by random networks model of the brain
and so uh
maybe our assessment of what is
surprising and what is not should be
changed maybe our
idea of what is a new model of the brain
should be changed maybe the new model
should be just a random network and we
should look for deviations from that
and maybe we should develop experiments
that are
designed to detect this newly surprising
thing things that we actually know now
are surprising
and so if you don't have any more time
this is basically the main message of my
talk today and from this point on what i
will do is to lead you through two
specific examples where
indeed it's pretty clear that we need to
reassess what the what is surprising
what should
be the null model that we're going to be
using
and um this will all feed into this
slide that you're seeing right now
okay so the first experiment that we are
the first model that we are going to
discuss this is a beautiful paper by ann
churchill zlatan jaffe told in 2020
neuron
and so what they did there is
they
recorded from the mouse brain as the
animal was
performing an auditory choice task there
is some clicks that are happening in the
background
and
um the animal needs to make a choice as
this clicks happening with one frequency
always another frequency and uh
depending on the number of these clicks
you know the standard psychometric
function like here on this plot v which
is taken from the majority at all paper
and then there is a beautiful
experimental setup where
multiple different
multiple different colors are used to
record different properties different by
different molecules
from the
from the brain as the mouse is doing uh
this
this recording and as a result um
after a lot of
quite
ingenious manipulation of the data
it's possible to identify which neurons
are excitatory which neurons are
inhibitory and it's possible to
understand uh what is the activity of
individual excitatory neurons and which
what the activity of individual
inhibitory neurons in the system and so
that's what shown in figure c here
and so type of question that one can ask
what was the original goal of this paper
was how well can one predict behavior of
the animal is animal going to make a
left choice or a right choice right um
how well is it possible to even
understand you know forget about the
behavior is it possible from the
activity of the neurons to understand
what the animal is hearing is hearing
the high frequency or the low frequency
signal
and then
the general ideas are that excitatory
neurons are the ones that code for
information and inhibitory neurons so
keep the activity to manageable levels
and so maybe one should be able to make
these predictions from excitatory
neurons but not from inhibitory ones and
so the question is is it really true can
one make uh classifications of the
stimulator by the animal from excitatory
neurons over inhibitory or from both
the main result of the paper was that
the inhibitory cells were almost as good
as the excitatory cells at making
predictions of whether
they it was a low frequency versus a
high frequency signal that the animal
has heard
and the paper has developed as intricate
neural net network model that was a la
that allowed uh this selectivity for the
high or low frequency signals both from
the
excitatory neurons in the network and
from the inhibitory neurons in the
network and from both
and so when we thought about this we
said you know can we try
a different null model right so what i
mean by this is that the
um
instead of looking at very structured
models for specific factory cells taught
to specific inhibitory cells and there
are pools of those and pools of this and
they're cross-interacting etc etc and
you need to add more and more and more
details to this specific couplings
uh in order to actually explain uh what
you see in experiment maybe we should
start with a different site not with a
structured network
being the
starting point but with the most
unstructured network being the starting
point and so what we did is we developed
a random recurrent neural network model
where you have
the pool of blue excited terrain neurons
which talk to each other different sizes
and they can indicate their activity
there is a pool of
red inhibitory neurons which talk to
each other and talk to the excitatory
neurons there are input signals which
project to both in
excitatory cells and inhibitory cells
and we of course tried input signals
projected only to excise three and only
inhibitory and all modifications you can
think of
and then this network sort of does some
kind of dynamics and then
after that one tries to
identify whether the inputs were high or
low frequency
of clicks based on some kind of
you know linear nonlinear classifier uh
read out from the excitatory neurons or
inhibitory neurons or
all on your neurons and in this
subsequent slides blue is always
excitatory red is always inhibitory and
black is always excitatory and
inhibitory this is similar to liquid
state machines architecture except that
we're not fine-tuning this architecture
in any way which is what's required for
liquid state machine this is just plain
venereal neural network in the ei
balanced state
okay
and so uh once we did that
then we could do all the same recordings
from this networks as
was done from the mouse right we could
try to understand if excitatory neurons
and inhibitory neurons are selective for
high or low frequency stimuli uh to
which extent as a selective
at which point in the dynamics of the
network they become selective
um
how good the selectivity is from either
the excitatory neurons or inhibitory or
from both and so on and so forth and i'm
just going to show you a small subset of
you know results that we found so for
example
uh one could ask um in many different
instances of this network realizations
we're having here 14 different
realizations of such networks um
what was
the
selectivity of individual excitatory
cells or inhibitory cells for either the
high or the low um
frequency
of clicks right if i look at an
individual cell
excitatory or inhibitory cell will i be
able to say even the small
probability but not a 50 50 probability
maybe it's 51 percent versus 49 can i
say whether the network was excited by
the
low or high frequency of clicks and so
what we see here this is on the figure
on the left again blues are excitatory
rather inhibitory essentially no
difference between the selectivity that
emerges in this network from excitatory
inhibitory cells and
the selectivity emerges because you know
even though it's randomly connected to
large networks there are some
fluctuations in the sound that you know
this particular neuron got connected to
you know that one but not this one with
such and such trends but not such a you
know another strengths and overall there
is going to be some small asymmetry this
particular neuron is going to be a bit
more responsive to high frequency
stimulus or low frequency stimulus and
then you
see that the selectivity is actually not
that high right it's in the ballpark
between 0.5 and
about 0.1 um
accuracy this is
the actual metric here is um the area
under the curve above 0.5 so there's
neurons of 0.6 area under the curve
selective and if you look at experiments
experiments are all in the range with
range between 0.1 and point 16 for the
neurons that they're recording from
right so the most selective neurons are
exactly in the same range as we are
recording in this in this simulated
neurons
and then you put them all together
and even though individual neurons are
are only weakly selective but when you
put hundreds of them together you can
easily
train a classifier that is going to
predict whether the animal has
experienced which was just experiencing
a
high or low frequency of stimuli and
this is what the plot on the right shows
again um
there
if we try to train from all of the
neurons xi3 excitatory inhibitory we do
slightly better than if we're training
from our excitatory inhibitory neurons
only but there is no statistically
significant difference between
excitatory neurons or inhibitory neurons
in representing which stimulus animal is
experiencing and the numbers you know
the ability of this network to classify
whether it was high frequency or clicks
or low frequency of clicks um you know
we're recording numbers anywhere in the
ballpark between 0.7 and 0.85 was maybe
one
exception for network number six and
then the experiments are also recording
the same accuracy 0.7.85
right so this
random network model does not just
qualitatively match what the experiments
produce but it quantitatively matches
what the experiments produce to within
one or two significant digits
and so the statement here is that you
know all of the experimental results
that were reported essentially all
experimental results that were reported
we were able to reproduce with the
uh random network model that i presented
and they matched the
theory and they predicted and and and
and the experiments matched each other
to within one and two significant digits
and so this emergency selectivity which
is nearly equal for both e and i cells
is expected in a random network it's not
an unexpected result that requires
fine-tuning and design of a network in a
very particular way no you expect it in
a random connection
and we can make predictions here in a
random network changing stimuli will
change the classifier support very
drastically but in a precisely designed
network that's not entirely not
necessarily the case so the changes
to classifiers based on changes in the
stimuli might actually explain or might
actually say whether we are um whether
the model of the random network we have
developed is actually the right model of
the experiment
in order to do that what one needs to be
measuring is stability of classification
multi-neuronal correlations not just
pairwise correlations that are measured
and so on and so forth
but it looks like this very simple
network is at least a good starting
point point a good new model for these
type of experiments and we need to build
on top of that
now let's switch gears a bit and we are
now going to look at the
mouse in the virtual maze experiment
this is a work by david tank's lab new
michelin was the first course or a prl
paper in 2020 so what's happening there
is we have a
mouse in the virtual maze it's running
through the maze and um
activity of neurons in hippocampus is
recorded and the question here is
actually very exploratory question
what are the interesting correlations
among these neurons
if i try to build a coarse grained large
scale model of this neural activity is
there are there any interesting
correlation that i'm emerging that are
surprising
and so in order to answer this what the
researchers have done is basically they
look as in picture b
uh they look at every individual neuron
they find neuron pairs that are the most
correlated with each other and they just
sum them together okay
and so this produces sort of a hyper
neuron and this is very similar to
coarse graining and the people using
statistical physics the idea is that we
are going to
combine together neurons that are
similar to each other the most related
so we're not throwing away much of
information because they are strongly
correlated with each other and we get
this a collective neuron hyperneuron and
made those hyper neurons would be a good
enough description of the underlying
neural dynamics
and so an interesting result emerges is
that if you start looking at various
correlations with a spatial temporal and
so on correlations between this coarse
grained merged neurons then the
correlation functions as a
measure of the
um
let's say this the temporal distance
that you know autocorrelation function
distance between the time points in
which you are calculating it start
developing beautiful
power loss and we all know that power
laws are not very common together in
physical systems in an animated system
so maybe this should be something
surprising that needs to be explained
so here is a model that we developed for
this
we have a network of neurons they are
not talking to each other at all they
are just on or off neurons and there is
a series of about five plus latent
variables and these latent variables are
randomly connected to the neurons rate
and variables undergo some some kind of
um random work dynamics and they
drive the activity of the neurons and
we're going to run the same type of the
coarse graining merging neurons together
as the michelangelo paper has
so this is what we get
if i look for example at the variance of
activity of this hyper neurons
uh and i plot it versus the cluster size
uh sort of the number of neurons put
together into one particular cluster
after the coarse graining
so if neurons were
completely
independent from each other
you add them together we're going to get
the law of large numbers
the central limit theorem and the
variance should grow as the
number of neurons in the um
in the in the cluster like number of
neurons combined together and in fact we
don't get that we get the variance which
grows with the uh power law of
1.367 plus minus 0009 and an experiment
when they did this type of analysis they
got 1.4 plus minus 06. it's a perfect
nearly perfect agreement
um
let's keep figure because i'm running
out of time for example in figure c
what's happening
is that we are looking at this activity
of these big clusters you know of
hundred neurons put together
hierarchically and i can calculate the
uh principal components calculate get
the eigenvalues of activity of these
clusters and plot this uh the size of
eigenvalues versus their rank versus a
number
and
if you see there is is a power law there
experimentally uh
0.71 plus minus 0.006 was measured and
we are recording in figure c from this
very simple simulations point 65 plus
minus 0.09 okay
thanks much to experiment in theory much
with each other at
two significant digits level
um even more interestingly
one can ask if i look at the activity of
these clusters as i get neurons together
into each other
the activity should become
it's the sum of many variables variables
are not quite independent from each
other if they were fully independent
then the activity of individual cluster
would just be a gaussian distributed
variable by the central limit theorem
but neurons are not independent they're
not fully
dependent on each other but they're
somewhat dependent and so maybe i will
not get a gaussian distribution but i
will get a distribution that looks
nearly gaussian
right or maybe not nearly gaussian maybe
it's going to be
away from a gaussian not let's see
what's going to happen and so we do this
in our system a gaussian here would be
this dotted line that you see in the
middle and what you see that as we was
grained the system you know we combine
neurons in groups of 16 32 64 128 you
start seeing that there is some kind of
a limit right the uh yellow and the
orange lines essentially on top of each
other so we reached the limit and we
didn't reach a gaussian
so the activity of this neurons is on
large scale very non-gaussian
and while i'm not showing this here this
plot is quantitatively matching exactly
what
was recorded in the
um
mr lam at all analysis of the
experiments from tanks
from time club
not qualitatively but quantitatively and
i want to stress this
and so
as a result here
essentially all reported experimental
results were reproduced by our model
within about two significant digits when
there's no null model
we have no idea what those latent
variables are uh that are needed in
order to drive the active neurons and in
some sense
the next step of this type of analysis
next step of such theory should be to
identify this latent variables and maybe
those latent variables are precisely the
relevant degrees of freedom on which
future theories of this particular part
of the brain need to be built i don't
know that
but what's clear is that we should
change what our new model is and what
our expectations are about what's
surprising and what's not surprising in
such experimental recordings power law
scalings are not surprising at all
in model with latent degrees of freedom
and it looks like they match the
experiments with very high accuracies
that will model is probably quite
reasonable
uh what it also means is that we need to
be designing experiments and analysis
not to identify those power loss in the
future but try to identify deviations
from those power laws right we need to
measure higher order correlations to see
whether they are meaningful or not we
need to
make
measurements with and without
perturbations to the brain because it
turns out that responses of
different new models to perturbations
are actually quite different and that
would allow us to make distinction uh
from
to understand whether the prediction the
model that we have built here is
actually the right model and so um
the summary from all of this
um
parts of the talk
i want to
say again that
i don't believe that the brain is random
right by no means
but
random networks are probably a good
starting point point
a good null model for
uh building theories of the brain
and it's very different from people
perform what people normally do in
modeling brain activity and with that i
again need to thank the organizers i
need to thank the uh people who have
contributed to this work mia and audrey
and i'm going to stop here thank you